the northern suburbs of st. Louis a
place where hope has long been
extinguished a place of appalling
neglect and decay of dilapidated homes
and vulnerable lives the place which by
day seems abandoned to its poverty and
which by night has surrendered to the
gun it is the same scene virtually every
night blue lights taped off streets
shootings and murder overwhelming
detectives here in a world where
reprisals are routine it's in my view at
in epidemic proportion that's going on
here this local church leader is almost
in despair what do you think is the
cause of all this gun violence what's
the main reason it's happening in my
mind it is the availability of guns mark
its guns everywhere children have guns
teenagers have guns senior citizens have
guns for protection guns everywhere he's
trying to get the message out to appeal
for sanity but behind the placards
pasted outside thousands of homes and
along hundreds of streets lurks an
uncomfortable truth for st. Louis and
for America what we found here is a
powerful example of what happens when
gun laws particularly tough background
checks are just swept away here on the
rundown streets of northern San Louis
it's meant more guns and more deaths
most gun owners in Missouri are
responsible but the state has some of
the most relaxed gun laws in America ten
years ago changes allowed private sales
with no checks
research shows an increase in the murder
rate since of 25 percent friends at Ida
grew a weird man just know you know sort
of friends like they like my family to
my brothers you know I've sent now for
those who live on the streets of
northern San Luis it is all about
self-preservation
wherever I go I take my fire if I go
anywhere here in the city of st. Louis
or anywhere just period just anywhere
you know you go one half kind of fear I
keep my fire oh I keep it on me like
identification the bullets get to find
there's no marksman here that got
perfect aim that I hit the target at
they're shooting at the bullet is just
flat and you can hit us either one of us
almost everywhere in northern San Luis
you hear stories of people killed in
random shootings or caught in the
crossfire it's exactly what happened to
24 year old Whitney Jones whose mother
and a friend are now campaigning for
change our gun laws are two legs it's
not enough effort putting into it my
daughter was shot with ak-47 that's a
weapon of mass destruction that's
military and I'm pretty sure the persons
or person they used it was not in the
military for them to be able to access a
gun like that just give me a sense of
what it's like to live with so much gun
violence in this community we used to
say we'll see you later now we said be
safe when you leave the house because
you don't know if you're gonna see these
people again and I think this is
everybody's story in our community now
you do you don't know when you leave the
house whether your make it back home
that day
but resistance to change here is evident
to the gun show we came across just
outside st. Louis here they have
contempt for tighter gun laws and
suspicion of the student protests
calling for them they had a tragedy you
get over the tragedy and you move on gun
control is not going to stop somebody
from killing somebody it does not do it
it does not happen you can ask any
person in here America's gun debate
fierce and unresolved even in the city
that's become the murder capital of this
country Marc Austin Sky News in st.
Louis